like the normal feminist take is to sit
around watching feminist Vlogs kind of a
report on like some random thing that
happens to the woman in Australia and
then the feminist comes up and says
that's a sign of how the world is this
woman got killed by a kangaroo in
Australia which means kangaroos hate
women and there's a sexist problem
[Laughter]
and that's that's the state of everyone
but it's not just unless that's one
you've heard of that's one you've just
heard of today yeah one of the cases
I'll be real and I say this is someone
who grew up in Saudi Arabia for 20 years
there are parts of the world that could
do with a healthy dose of you I don't
even like the term feminism let's just
let's call it let's call it
egalitarianism yeah yeah there are there
are which is what she just said and he's
not lazy to say that yeah exactly it's
not a lazy feminism
I'm saying in the West in the West in
the Western and so so we're doing okay
I'm I'm talking about the West I I and
I'm saying if you're in 2022 blaming the
patriarchy for why you cannot succeed as
a woman in 2022 in the west you're lazy
I agree okay you're just using it as an
excuse I would say because you're lazy
for example in this Western World and
right now one of the issues I have with
a lot of your viewers Pearl no offense
guys but I'll be if if need be is the
fact that actually
there's people saying women shouldn't
run Society if I'm just that's the whole
point don't be making about man and
woman make it be about person person
must be capable person must be aware
person must be responsible it's not
about man and woman that's what we're
trying to get at do you get what I mean
80 of people in Europe believe in gender
equality so this idea that there's
people walk around who are telling you
to go in the kitchen and make sandwich
is nonsense the fact is we all most the
average person absolutely in the Europe
and in the west already believes in
gender equality so what are you talking
about so the existence of this specific
podcast in this show and the reason why
we even there's any interest is because
of the fact that those views are still
exist and they're actually growing even
more now and that's why now we're having
clashes because people are starting to
misunderstand what a modern woman is
they're starting to misunderstand what
the label feminism means do you get what
I mean so at this point is yeah it's
still a man's world women now want to
say forget about being a man's world
it's a person's world is humans world
we're all in it together let's actually
stop trying to say I'm better than you
and you're worse than this we if I'm
better than you are doing something I'm
better than you whether I'm a man or
woman forget about that it's that simple
quick so sorry quick one when Overman
takes you out were you expect him to pay
if a man takes me out I'll share I'll be
like you know you want to split and if
it says
do you know why I do that I do that
because it puts me in a situation to
understand where his mind is at if you
accept me paying I already know what
that says about you so your life
it means that you're either just logical
50 50 person you could mean that you're
broke or it could just mean that you're
just like if you want a child me okay
okay
that goes completely against your
feminist ideology and the whole
everyone's equal though no that's
completely against it that goes down
because this is the problem this is why
people this is what this is okay okay no
no no this is this is why this is why I
have a platform and I have an audience
and they're not misogynistic they just
don't like that feminist only like
equality when it doesn't or only
complain about equality when it doesn't
benefit them and so so you you like you
you enjoy inequality when it benefits
you but when it doesn't now you're
complaining and that's the whole issue
it's not like a misogyny like the like
they hate women they don't think women
can be in charge whatever it's it's that
feminists are not authentic and they're
not honest okay so and I'm gonna tell
you to interrupt you my sister let me
just explain to you okay
I was looking for masculine man actually
I would want you to be better at
finances than me because ideally that's
not a headache I want to deal with I
want to do with a home so if I'm asking
you if you're gonna pay and you say yes
okay it's not about equality it's about
whether or not you're going to position
yourself in that situation to be better
than me which benefits the partnership
because one day I'm going to be at home
having kids you should be out there
working yeah
a lot of women now want to be treated
traditionally yeah
but if you want to do the traditional
thing you can't pick and choose when to
be traditional you might have to do
everything all the way like okay okay if
you if you want traditional outcomes are
you virgin no okay so that's what I'm
saying I'm saying how can you ask for
traditional outcomes like the man to pay
when we're not traditional women it's
not about traditional what I'm don't
care if you're traditional not what I'm
saying
what I want I want to work hard and I
want you to work I want to work smarter
I want you to work harder so those
questions that will mean something if
you're financially better than me
quality because that's what I'm saying
like feminists only want equality when
benefits somebody that works harder
because I work better bringing you want
to depend on him that's why
it's not feminist that's better than you
so you can pay for your stuff
stop this nonsense right now
I want to be in that moment where I'm
testing what you're about I know that
I'm smart I know that if I bring what I
bring to the table is working smart
what do you bring what did you bring to
a man do you do your femininity Purity
and youth do you have femininity Purity
youth femininity Purity and intentions
and yes
I'm sorry I'm sorry you're 29 that's not
youthful it is
you can't be like close to halfway
through your life and Sam
can I just say quickly
to quote somebody that I love uh
women age like milk not like wine uh I
know you hate to hear that
I'm gonna give you I'm gonna give you
why I'm gonna give you why listen to me
so much more than I would have sex I
don't care this is why I can come to you
honestly just a quick question and I
know it sounds weird but let me land as
you say do you think lions and lionesses
have a better relationship than tigers
and tigrises do you know the difference
of those relationships because what
you're describing is a lioness who's not
equal to a lion right but what you want
and what you saying you want is to be a
tigress who's equal to a tiger tiger
says and tigers don't act anyway close
to lines and lionesses you want that
Lion in your house but you also want to
be the lion that's not how that works no
right I want a man that fulfills a role
that I am not going to fulfill that's a
line in line
of things and let me tell you about it
what you just said is opposite
house a lioness is not equal to a male
lion that's just a fact I'm not gonna
argue with nobody about it there's
Discovery Channel for you there it's
it's Wikipedia there that's equal a
tigress as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible